agathe et dont on est d'accord c'est
peut-être des questions personne bien
sûr bas alors est ce que claude je vais
trouver un appartement d'ici fin avril
même apple plaza nous fais toi à toi
c'est pire est pas que son mobile me
battant hier joint entre deux âges e
reçoit entre frères et un chantre de et
vous visiterez quelque chose qui n'est
pas très loin de chez vous non actuelle
mais je crois qu'elle appelle chez elle
rien ou dévisser la benauge en quoi elle
déménage en couple mais oui parce que
les menace avec un vieux comme un homme
et que je connais actuellement que vous
connaissez déjà
bouder les attendait elle pose une
question il a déjà embrassé sur la
bouche absolument raison déjà chez
cannes où ils ont délogé de sa barbe etc
qui n'est pas terminée j'aime l'idée
aussi je pense savoir de qui s'anime
achète drucker
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il est dans la musique
pas du tout non dans le clip il habitait
seule bas vous allez habiter 4s qui est
dans le monde des médias non plus aa je
me suis trompé ce qu'il est dommage que
ce qu'il est dans le monde 2 vient de la
restauration à la la finance et damien
sinon baladeur losail ça doit être ça on
rigole je n'ai personne bon et on va
papa voulait dire n aient ou non